man ist ja unterwies mehr so schnell
ruhe gekommen ich weiß auch nicht ich
habe heute gegeben okay der einen tut
ist laut mtv.com freunde zu einer runde
und ich sage sonst sich herzlich
willkommen freunde trotzdem spielt mit
hallo herzlich willkommen meine bekommen
zu machen aber nicht nach alter das ist
so nervig
ich hab euch den clip weiter ja wir
gerade im sturm gespielt aufs tornetz
kanal schaut diese mit dem link den ich
euch in die beschreibung packen und dann
hier mal wieder ein normales ppp da ich
vor produziere und wahrscheinlich nicht
siehst du vor wofür das werde ich nicht
verraten
es ist eine top secret ist ein top
secret ähnlicher weise gemeine ein top
secret verstehst du gehörst du reisen zu
können
17 gar nicht da ich habe fünf weisen ja
gibt hier denke ich war sehr gut bei
stimme ihn also einen schritt einmal
auch nicht und jetzt kommt dann wieder
die runde wurde richtig scheiße wirst du
selber aufnehmen
ja das können wir sehr gut deswegen
nämlich auch inzwischen immer nur noch
unten wo ich schlecht und meine partner
gut man nicht sieht von dem was die
machen das finde ich nicht in ordnung
doch nicht weil du machst es ist nicht
alleine ich bin eine welt paris in
sachen alter schwede wie habe ich den
denn gerade ich habe beides erlaubt das
waren beides tanks und hatten die hatten
bessere schwerter es war sehr zäh series
ich habe aber auch irgendwie komisch
geklickt muss ich sagen aber es war
nichts ich habe gestern mir mal so eine
technik angesehen wie ein paar kids
klicken das recht krank alter weise
taktiken nämlich total klicken noch
trasse höher ist es sowieso die taste
tastet die andere seite kommt und ich
bin echt nicht gut weil ich komme ich
komm rüber ich hoffe ich bekomme hier
grafing table aufstellen und wir müssen
alles geben was sind die denn ich hab
gerade eben die zweierteams der ob das
multitasking
aber ich muss jetzt auch ein bisschen
hierbei hatte ich noch mal ich komme
habe ich das hinkriege kommt heran
an diesen ich würde so etwas tut das gut
ich habe für mich baustopp story eines
bewusst der andere ist verschiedenes
gewinn der coach
oder ich kann nicht weg kommen wie immer
ist die blöcke vor wie abgebaut
ok hat er einfach seine mieter würde
elendig verrecken lassen so
rübergekommen mit ihm und politikern die
nicht abgebaut haben
wir haben uns aber auch nicht abgebaut
oder ich hab meine und abgepackt
nachteile hell so läuft das also so bist
du drauf
hier sind die ja schon hast du alle oder
trester konzern des schreckens nee nee
ich nicht jackson zwei der schule
bekommen
wie kann man das tnt ausbildende mit
redstone oder in ihren reaktionen oder
mit links euch kommen gerade ich komme
zurück ich bin steinplatte wie krieg
kann schnell eine steinplatte oh jetzt
bremst ihn nicht mehr wollen wir abbauen
können würden nicht mehr lange okay gut
ja die sind schon ziemlich laut und zu
lande lass das mal nicht machen wo war
das noch einer geht noch einer geht
jetzt einfach ziemlich gefräst ein
hammer eines dauern wird weil mit die
lassen oder mitnehmen da ist gar schon
bei mir
rabin war nur noch zwei herzstück die
alle gleich aber ich habe jetzt
mittlerweile der angel
ich habe mit dem krieg sie unter ich
gehe davon aus die kombi kommt aber wenn
so ran komme ich weiß nicht ob ihr habt
ihr das mister schalke 04
wenn du das schaffst du ein
turnschuhe protection 2 habe ich glaube
nicht dass hier ankommen wenn man den
geschichten vorteil ist dass ich gab es
eine sehr spannende runde
bisher gefällt mir gar nicht kommentiert
und und flieg alters und verarscht mich
immer wenn ich kommentiere bist du bist
krank weil das ist denn ich find das
entspannen wenn ich krank dass er erst
jetzt mag ich öfters tank bietet deshalb
schon gesehen weil wir rangehen
wie kommt ihr gleich sobald ihr das
macht er jetzt ne das ist die große
frage
okay jetzt kann ich soll dagegen schon
wieder zurück das ist echt cool so wie
mit den spielen kann
die angst vor der angst das krasseste
mich einfach verreise mit der maus ist
der schalke 04 in das licht der welt
direktor kameras sogar auch alle mal war
unten rum laufen im moment nicht gut an
würde doch im norden schaffen weil die
ja kann man nun sicher
ja sicher was wir sehen aktuell sus
hervest wieso kein zweiter muss jetzt
weiter
genau aber ich habe einen weggeworfenen
sich hierauf hin da ist jetzt weiter
wieso kann ich dir angel nicht jeder auf
jeden fall tacke
der hintergrund sondern wusste es auf
dem baum ist der eine also der eine ist
jetzt in der facebook gerade weil nach
der die andere steht da oben der andere
stimmt wenn die mitte gehen einfach zu
heiß kalt auf die scheiße aber ob da
erhält ihr wird auch was ist mit ist für
zeitungszusteller will und da ist gerade
jemanden verzaubern vorübergehen also
hier mussten müsse wieder hoch kommt
nämlich jetzt stehen elecom nicht kam
nicht aber halt wo ihr das ja aber auch
noch martin fuhsy abstand dahinter und
ok sehr gute entscheidung gewesen die
basics drauf da die chemie als mister
schalke ist dann gleich so fasst mir auf
den anruf ich habe interessante reise
assistance erst nach der show jeder
kommt der kommt wieder einer kommt
wieder ein und da kommt wieder einer
direkt hier sind spaß hatte ich habe 19
diaz übrigens wenn wir verbrennen oder
willst du jetzt glaube ich deshalb
einfach die hände auf messen wir noch
okay nur noch ein herz gleich vorweg
homburger eishockey chemotherapie oder
kaum noch wir könnten ganz ganz schnell
kippen hin schnell würden ich probiere
noch zu gehen und nicht sein dass wir
hier keine die scheiße okay es kaum noch
welche von der seite achtung im kombi
kommt ja jetzt gerade
ich habe ich kaum noch leben ich bin
hinter dir
okay du hast du richtig bedauern scheiße
spannende runde alter bisher leiter
fixed was gerissen
ich habe eigentlich mit genommen bzw der
direkt abgestaubt immer noch eine dran
oder einen einen eine million kunden
das waren 7 ziemlich gut hat spaß
gemacht hat es nick dinge wahrscheinlich
ist es klar dass alle zu uns kommt es zu
schnell der angenehm wieder wenn du
einfach als tank spiegel sind direkt
eine kult band ist also ich hab enkes
wesentlich stärker als es ging es hier
also es ist halt nur wirklich richtig
krass stark wenn einer perle direktors
yahoo studie gab es ja auch keine
schutzzeit also ich hab mir gerade
richtige oper jazz bekommt diesmal links
hinter der hinter dir hinterher kommen
jetzt wo ich dachte die welt schon da
sind alle ok wollte hier und hier
speziell die tiere hier ihre ich hab'
ich hab' ich gebe ja mal welche hier
einfach noch mal die meinung vor die
kiste
ja ich weiß 16 rangiert auf die gegner
fokussiert brauchst du noch an equipment
nicht sondern ich hab dir hier dass ich
krank
ich habe die ratings weisheit nicht ab
die schon wieder irgendwas am start
die gucken und das nicken und horn ist
nicht meine art wir jetzt nicht gleich
ankommen mit mir rechnen
robert hinter uns ok ich hab' ich habe
ich hätte jetzt geht es gut
1 und 2
danke erst mal zu denen und weil zudem
wurde sich auch gerade war ich einfach
kills gregor pottmeyer zudem einen
mitgegeben vor so runtergefallen
zukäufe wird es möglich
studienplan ihren glückwunsch auch du
hast dich verstanden dass das system
nicht funktioniert wir alle email
schreiben
man schreibt ja oder man sagt ja
wirklich jede runde dazu jetzt gerne
auch noch mal also wir schreiben müsste
natürlich in runden nie zurück deswegen
macht es eigentlich überhaupt keinen
sinn dass man anfängt zu chatten
heute ich hab mir erzählt dass bei so
einem schulfest bei uns nie voll
belagert wurde
man darf ich dein handy nummer yakubu
also fragen dann hat echt manchmal ein
bisschen merkwürdig also da interessiert
mich tatsächlich inzwischen schon mal
was bei den leuten dass sie meinen das
wäre so als wenn ich mein gott man ist
ja unterwies mehr so schnell ruhe kommt
ich weiß auch nicht ich habe halt
gegeben
okay der eine tut ist laut enders pferde
gerne doch okay erdogans verlorenen
leben eigentlich auch nicht wirklich nur
so konnten wir per computer private
renten so gegeben werden
echt nice session ein happy end
die kamera ist so weit weg ich kann da
nicht erfasst